PROFESSOR: We've talked a
lot about de Broglie saying
that the wavelength
is given by h over p.
But we have not said much
yet about the frequency
of the waves.
So what is the frequency
of those matter waves?
So what is the frequency--
frequency--
of the matter waves.
So de Broglie did answer
that same question.
And the answer was
obtained by analogy.
We have p equal h bar k.
And he said, well, just
like the wavelength
is determined by the momentum,
we'll have e equal h bar omega.
So the frequency--
so this equation
is the one that now
completes the story.
Omega is equal to e over h bar.
Fixes omega in
terms of the energy.
And we're going to
say a few things.
In fact, this will be an
interesting digression
into an important
subject about waves
that illustrates why this
answer makes a lot of sense.
And that's, really, all
you can do at this moment.
This is a postulate
of quantum mechanics.
That you do this thing,
and with this, you
get quantum mechanics.
So the best thing we
can do is to explain
why it makes sense
in a number of ways,
and then hope that the
theory that you built
makes full sense.
So I want to remind you
about velocities of waves.
So if you have a wave now
that it has k and omega--
you have this thing. k minus
omega, wave with a phase.
kx minus omega t.
Then there is something
called the phase velocity.
And it's given by omega over k.
It's the velocity in which the
nodes and maxima of this plane
wave move.
So let's see if this
makes some sense.
Omega over k is the
same thing as e over p.
We're nonrelativistic,
so let's continue.
1/2 mv squared over mv.
And this seems a little strange.
1/2--
v. So if I have a
particle, you see,
this is matter waves of
energy e and momentum p.
And e is 1/2 mv squared, the
velocity of the particle.
p is equal to mv.
And now, somehow
this wave seems to be
moving with half the
speed of the particle.
That looks pretty bad.
What's going on?
Well, this is the
usual story with waves.
If the wave itself doesn't--
a wave, a plane wave
carries no real information.
It's not the signal.
So many times when you try
to represent the particle--
a little bit of information
traveling-- representing it
with a plane wave is
actually quite wrong.
You have to represent
it with a wave packet.
And therefore, this
phase wave velocity
being one half of the
velocity of the particles
seems to just confirm the idea
that, first, these waves are
a little strange.
And second, phase velocity is
not very meaningful physically.
The velocity that this more
meaningful is v group velocity.
And it's d omega dk evaluated at
the value k that you're using.
k is a proxy for momentum.
So d omega dk may
depend on k and omega.
So if it's d omega,
dk is a function.
Which value should you use?
Well, the value at the k
that you're propagating.
And this would be the
same as d omega dk.
Is because of the constant
separating-- the same as de vp.
But what is the kinetic energy
in terms of the momentum?
We wrote it last time.
p squared over 2m.
That's the kinetic energy
expressed in terms of momentum.
So this is d dp of
p squared over 2m.
Write p equal mv and you'll
recover the kinetic energy.
And this is just--
because of the 2--
p over m, which is the
velocity of the particle.
And this is the reason
people believe de Broglie.
De Broglie made sense
because the group velocity
of this [? package
?] would be correct.
And that's a very
beautiful result.
Actually, it's true
relativistically, as well.
If you put the energy and
the momentum in relativity,
this answer comes out exactly
the same, perfectly well.
So to a large
degree, since it also
works for energy and
momentum in relativity,
there was a motivation
from relativity
that I want to quote, although
not elaborate on it too much.
So--
the motivation--
is that in special relativity--
relativity--
the components of the energy
divided by c and the momentum
form a 4-vector.
Just like position and time
forms a 4-vector and transform
nicely about--
with Lorenz transformation--
e and p form a 4-vector.
Nevertheless, when
you consider phases--
like this, and you have x
and t that form a 4-vector,
the good behavior
of phases also imply
that k and omega
form a 4-vector.
In fact, omega-- in relativity,
omega over c and the k vector--
form a 4-vector.
You see, in all the
equations we've written--
and de Broglie-- de Broglie
in three dimensions or more,
really, is p vector
equal h bar k vector.
And k is usually used for the
magnitude of this k vector.
So this is also 4-vector
in special relativity.
And therefore, vectors are
things that transform nicely.
So it makes sense to
say that one 4-vector is
equal to another 4-vector.
Because if it's true
in one reference frame,
it will be true in
every reference frame.
So it's almost irresistible
to make them equal.
And de Broglie, in some sense,
said this is equal to h bar.
That's de Broglie.
The interesting thing is that
this is true relativistically.
But actually,
nonrelativistically, you
can make sense of this and set
it equal to be the same things.
And the phase velocities, group
velocities all makes sense.
Certainly, we've now said
for [? minor ?] particles
that e is equal to j bar omega.
But another statement would
be that, yes, indeed, Einstein
said that.
That for photons, e was
equal to h bar omega or h nu.
And therefore, yes,
whatever happens for photons
happens for this matter waves.
And so also, so this
is another argument.
Group velocities is one.
Special relativity
is another reason.
And of, course photons.
Einstein--
said that e is equal h nu,
which is equal to h bar omega.